your mind is a bit like soup it has to
be stirred up all the time and then
interesting vegetables float to the
surface and so on
Dyson meant Brady
so potassium metal is very reactive one
of my colleagues who used to work with
it described it as evil
look at it beautiful silvery shiny metal
and you can imagine the periodic table
bit like a family photograph and looking
at the periodic table over and over
again you discover new things and it
reminds you of relationships which you
might have forgotten
oh wow and expect it to be quite so Wow
to generate a nice P for phosphorus
it's nice sunny weather in Stockholm
take the exit left
hi do you speak English
where are we look up yonder to the left
oh whoa
I I've never spent that much money on a
book and middly it's no Harry Potter
what are you coming it is too
it's a periodic table that's the first
one I've had with the new elements 114
and 116 but they're very fussy they only
want some leaves and others ones
finishing and they need to do more we
will need more elements
you